we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question that i actually
i've been thinking about addressing this
and because it's coming in a voicemail i
will actually talk about it take a
listen to this is a message for david
and pat i was clicking onto some of your
videos and i noticed that some of them
were preceded by ads which may be very
happy while others were not
is there any rhyme or reason as to which
ones get monetized because if the
advertisers are trying to avoid
controversy i saw ads on clips about
obamacare and trump deleting tweets and
Donald Trump jr. yeah I don't get it
but anyways I hope you're getting more
money these days keep up the great work
okay very good question so listen here's
the deal
ad D monetization on YouTube is still a
problem we are getting ads but we were
getting fewer ads and we're also getting
lower quality ads meaning that each ad
pays less the D monetization is
relatively haphazard and both Pat and I
pay attention to when videos become d
monetized on YouTube and sometimes Pat
will come to me and he'll say did you
see that video a totally innocuous topic
is d monetized but somehow our video
about Isis is fully monetized and
running ads and I will say to Pat yeah I
did see that and I couldn't understand
it and it is very very weird I mean I
think the rhyme and reason behind it is
in principle content that would not be
advertiser friendly as a result of not
being what would generally be called
family-friendly is not supposed to have
ads on it or have fewer ads on it
whereas you know really uncontroversial
videos what did a Ryan Seacrest say the
latest American Idol is that show even
still on the air I couldn't even tell
you that's the type of stuff that would
have full ads but the algorithm is
clearly not working that well because
not only do we have lots of videos that
are totally totally benign and tame and
completely WorkSafe lose monetization we
also have videos that we put them up and
Pat and I will both say yeah it's just
not going to be monetized and never an
issue ads just run so I wish I could
have a better
the only answer as to the rhyme or
reason is it depends on what is mostly
an automated algorithm and sadly the
algorithm is not working nearly as well
as it should on today's bonus show the
EPA is planning to spend $25,000 on a
soundproof booth for the EPA director
Scott Pruett not exactly a good look if
you're trying to show that you are open
and transparent there is also a new
index that will help people gauge the
food diversity of certain regions or
areas and because Roy Moore did win his
primary on Tuesday
we will talk through the seven most
inflammatory things that Roy Moore has
said and really the list could probably
be seventy but we're gonna pick out
seven of the wackiest things that Roy
Moore has said join me on the bonus show
david pakman.com slash membership get
instant access patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can also get access to
the bonus show at the $5 level either
way gets you on the bonus show and
that's really the priority we'll speak
to you then